so solving pokemon blue with a huge
regular expression I'm going to tell you
about this problem because I've been
obsessed with it for like three years I
saw somebody tweet about the last
session saying like bing bang khan has
this underlying theme of trying to make
sense of the world with tools this is
not that talk this talk is a frantic
highly obsessed talk about a problem
that I believe exists and nobody else
does right ok so I don't have time to
explain all the practicalities I should
I should set a timers what I should say
because I was I will go over ok so so I
don't have time to really explain all
the practicalities it's like a huge
problem as it turns out so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give a brief
explanation of what the game is explain
what my claim means what do I mean when
I say solve pokemon blue try to convince
you it can be done and give you some
intuition for how and then pretty much
everything else I'm just gonna like
punch right okay so pokemon blue it's
Gameboy game came out in like 1996 or
1995 basically you play an 11 year old
boy you want to be the best pokemon
trainer on the planet and so one day you
wake up and you tell your mom and she's
like yeah ok that's fine go fight
strangers yeah all boys leave home
Sunday right and so you meet this funny
old guy and the funny old guy gives you
like one of these Pokemon he's captured
and you just start wandering the world
right so so as you wander the world you
encounter Pokemon you try to capture
them you bump into people and then you
fight them duel style right so and
whoever's like Pokemon faints the last
or like doesn't faint like they win and
they get all the experience points and
that's how you like little up ok so ok
so if you're like me like after like an
hour and you realize that the game is
really just like wandering around in the
grass trying to like find Pokemon right
it's like it's like 18 hours of this
right and it's like what like I'm an
adult like I don't have time for this
stuff right like I have to think about
adult things like like you know like tax
exemptions and like listen to jazz and
other stuff right like I just like what
I want to do is I want to think really
hard about the moves that I
gonna make I want to write them down
right so like LDR a left down right a
button and then I want to put that into
a regular expression and I want the
regular expression to accept if and only
if that we've said as a winning game of
Pokemon blue okay so there are lots of
advantages of this approach
you can check it in to get for example
you can do pull requests you can do code
review you can be like you wanted to
turn left there actually just so you
know and but most importantly and the
crux of my claim that you want to solve
that we're trying to sell a pokemon blue
is the regular expression actually
precisely specifies all winning games at
pokemon blue so it's not a little better
like it's a lot better right like your
alternative is pressing buttons for like
20 hours until you find a particular
winning you know mousette and if you
think that that's not that big of a deal
you're like why why should I care about
this problem just listen okay so there
are four point 83 million copies of
pokemon blue that were sold five point
zero zero two million copies of pokemon
red which is basically an identical game
if you assume that the average player
spent twelve hours on this right then an
aggregate the human race has spent 118
million two hundred thousand person
hours on this right think about that
it's like the potato blight from your
brain right like like it's just it's
just a thing that's swept across the
country giving people smaller homework
scores and like and stuff like that and
some people never recovered
right like think about that it had a
profound impact on our unlike the way
that we process stuff and i just believe
that like if we're to time-travel back
to 1994 what I'm proposing is we could
actually write this regular expression
down put it on a bunch of CDs and just
give that to the kids for Christmas
right or
or whatever whatever your whatever the
relevant December holiday or a birthday
is right so I'm just saying you know
like in aggregate we would be better off
okay but this is all a digression okay
so like how is this even possible so I'm
gonna make two claims okay first claim
pokemon blue is a finite it has a finite
number of states okay so the game is a
grid you press left you go will left one
square you press right you go one square
there's no continuous part right like
original Super Mario Brothers you're
like marching along in a line right
pokemon blue is not like that there are
a finite number of things that you can
do claim to it turns out that there is a
formal correspondence between regular
expressions and finite state machines I
don't have time to explain it or to
prove it but there's a smart guy here at
this nice book you can go read it if you
want okay so what exactly do I mean
let's clarify some things okay so when I
say finite state machine I mean a
collection of states where there's like
a well governed transition a well a well
structured transition function that
tells you how you transition between the
states okay so in this case you have a
very simple finite state machine and you
start in the initial state you press a
you go to the middle state then you
press B and you go to the accept state
okay and then if you do anything else
like you reject right so if you think
about it this is kind of like this
regular expression a B right it's like
not a complex example but I think what
we're going to try and do is to show how
you would actually transform this into
that regular expression so so at the
outset I'll say like because the talk is
only like ten minutes
assuming I speak really fast sorry
nearby who does the transcriptions of is
we need to like sort of simplify the
model and come up with something that I
can actually explain in ten minutes
we want a smaller version of pokemon
blue I'm calling it Pokemon move it's
not Pokemon new pokemon Moo right okay
so okay and then after that hopefully
I'll have time to give you some hints
about what you need to actually solve
this in like a practical way okay so so
basically pokemon Moo we're gonna
restrict ourselves to finding regular
expressions that solve mazes okay so you
take this small asking maze the hash tag
things those are
walls the S is to start the easy exit
and this is a slightly more complicated
version of the previous state machine
basically it allows you to like travel
back from the middle state so you can go
like right one and then left and then
right and then left but the trick is you
have to go to rights in order to get to
the accept right so like this accepts
like right move right move that takes
you to the accept state right left right
left right left right right that takes
you to the next step except state but
like right left doesn't right so you
think about what this would look like in
a regular expression it should look
something like this
you have RL star right so you can do RL
as much as you want as long as you end
with two R's right okay hopefully this
makes sense so so now the question of
like how do we actually formalize that
transformation so we want to take the
state machine we want to turn it into a
regular expression basically we're going
to use an algorithm known as the state
removal method the intuition is like
what if we remove this middle state
right like how would we have how could
we make an equivalent regular expression
so basically you can see like if you if
you look at this like the the edge from
the start to the from the start to the
end state would just end up being like
RR right so our R now becomes one edge
the RL thing that we saw before just
becomes like a self-loop on the initial
state so you can go RLR LRL RR right so
there's this this is even more
embellished version of the same thing in
real pokemon if you're up against a wall
and you try to move into the wall you
don't go like through the wall right
like you you bounce off the wall and you
end up where you started right so for
example in the start state s if you go
up you don't like go through the wall
you just end up and start state again so
we've added these little funny self
circles to indicate what the self
transitions are for each of these
squares this only makes it slightly more
complex so so you can basically take the
same approach approach in principle
which is like you still have this RL
thing but in the middle of it you have
you can also go like like if you just
trace along the map you can go right up
up up up up left right and you end up
back at the same start
the same start space right so um it's
not super important that you understand
all the intricacies of this just that
you understand conceptually that there
is a transformation and the
transformation makes sense because
you're trying to just like collapse all
of these edges down into a single a
single edge so once once you once you
find you know once you find that
self-loop transition you can combine it
with the original self loop so you can
go oh by the way the end I forgot to
take out so don't worry about the end
there's no end transition but the but
now we have like a regular expression
you look at this regular expression
that's read at the top here where we've
added this new self loop transition this
specifies all of the ways that you can
start at the starting place and end up
back at the start right so so that's
what it signifies so the remaining thing
to do is to try and connect the start
and the end position you apply something
similar basically the intuition is you
want to go right and then down but along
the way you could go like write write
write write write write down write or
like any number of these things so so
this write down right and then right up
star thing that you see is just trying
to capture that idea that you can you
once you hit that node is like if you if
you like sort of hit the wall a bunch of
times you can do that as much as you
want before you go down and you win
so Pokemon mu has because it's so simple
like the data model is fairly simple you
basically have like four or five types
of of square I don't so basically it's
like entrance/exit wall grass ground but
the transition model for this is pretty
simple you basically have you know you
have one one transition for each button
so each button represents you doing
something to pokemon blue so like if you
press up you go up one square if you
press down you go down one square we
added or and concat which is like this
regular expression stuff you see at the
top right here so and that's so that we
can collapse the states down so I don't
have time to explain what this algorithm
does it's actually pretty concise
relatively like what I expected
if you want to understand it can come
find me after the talk I think the
important thing to recognize here is
that not necessarily that you understand
how this transition happens but what is
crazy is like or well I should say what
is surprising is that these well maybe
not surprising I guess it was it's not
surprising like like when you think
about it like obviously these are gonna
get huge but it was surprising to me
when I received this AWS bill which is
for $9,000 so I explained this to the
nice people at AWS that this was a
mistake and it turns out if they believe
you sometimes they just expunge the debt
so okay so practicalities okay so I just
I just want to cover really quickly some
of the things that some of the ways this
this state model differs from the actual
pokemon blue state model so in
particular the like pokemon blue is like
much more complex right like not only
does your location matter but all the
objects locations in the entire game
matter whether you pick them up matter
how many of each item you're holding
which pokemon you have what their moves
are what their levels are all of this
basically anything you would want to
encode in a state file like a save file
you need to represent that inside the
state which just makes the the the state
space explode the thing that is
important to recognize is that a core
the fundamental notion of equality
between these states is what helps us
develop a sensible transition function
so two states are equal if and only if
all of these values are the same between
between two states right so the
transition function is actually I think
the most important most interesting part
which I'm sad I can't talk about so
first of all it's really complex you
can't get this information necessarily
from map data sometimes you have to read
the code which is like the z80 assembly
like so like if you talk to somebody and
they're like oh follow me into this
other place you're like oh great thanks
for right like like it's like it becomes
really hard because then you have to
figure out how to wire that transition
up manually but the most interesting
thing is like how do you deal with
randomness because you are walking
through the grass and you have these
random encounters so when I first
started this I I just like assumed like
a random seed and then that makes the
rest of the random numbers deterministic
but then that explodes your state space
exponentially and you never finished
processing it I realize later that you
can you
probabilistic regular expressions where
the transitions are probabilistic if you
want to talk about that I will talk your
[ __ ] ear off about that yeah okay so
I think you get the point right it's
actually a lot easier now I did this
like originally for like last year's
talks but like in the interim like the
open-source disassembly is a Pokemon
I've gotten super good so you don't have
to like you know like open up a hex
editor and be like what the heck am i
doing right so so if you wanted to do
this like you could it's definitely not
complete like I'm trying as hard as I
can to save all those hours for us at
the end of the day I would say it's kind
of effective so sorry for the false
advertising and that's all I got
[Applause]